[Music]
jordan peterson was a clinical
psychologist practicing in canada when
he got into a fight with the canadian
government
over his right to say what he believes
is true
that catapulted him into the position he
occupies now which is
one of the world's most important one of
its last really public intellectuals
he's written a brand new book 12 new
rules to life
we just had a long and fascinating
genuinely fascinating conversation with
him on a new episode of tucker carlson
today it's just out on fox nation
here's part of it you made your decision
2016 not to say what the government of
canada was prepared to force you to say
you decided i can't do that it violates
my conscience
my soul's at stake i'm not doing it
looking back
on that decision five years later your
life is completely different from what
it was
are you happy that you made that
decision was it worth it
well i wouldn't say i'm happy that i
made the decision i i wouldn't say that
my life has been particularly happy over
the last five years it's been
stressful beyond comprehension for a
variety of reasons but
and i would say um being pilloried on a
regular basis
publicly is definitely part of that um
but you know you you make your decisions
in life and i decided when i was very
young i'm in my mid-20s that i was going
to say what i believed and see what
happened
i talked to you earlier in the talk
about adventure you know about
the adventure of truth and i don't think
i'm happy
about what has happened and i certainly
have dragged my family through their
fair share of
well both hell and and also
incomprehensible opportunity
it's expanded our lives in both
directions to a tremendous degree
but it's certainly been an adventure
it's not been dull
and i don't believe that it i don't
believe that it was a mistake
whatever happens as a consequence of
telling the truth is the best thing that
can
happen it doesn't really matter how it
looks to you at the moment or maybe even
across the years
because you have to it's it's a it's a
it's an article of faith in some sense
do you believe that reality is better
constituted as a consequence of truth or
falsity if you believe that reality is
best constituted
as a consequence of truth then you have
a responsibility to speak the truth
and you can't assess the consequences
and say well that was a mistake because
part of the decision that reality is
best constituted
as a consequence of the truth is the
decision that no matter what happens
is the best if it's a consequence of
telling the truth
and so that's what i conclude it's like
this is what happened because i said
what i had to say
as clearly as i could say it and that's
as good as it could be
now whether or not that's good well it's
good compared to all possible
alternatives
all possible realistic alternatives
that's an article of faith as far as i'm
concerned you know our culture is
predicated on the idea
that truth in speech is of divine
significance it's the fundamental
presupposition of our culture
well if you believe that then you act it
out
and you take the consequences
you're going to take the consequences
one way or another you know
so you want the truth on your side
or do you want to hide behind falsehoods
that's the question do you want to hide
behind falsehoods you can watch a full
interview the inspirational interview
with jordan peterson by going
to foxnation.com and we hope you will
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else